for more than two months a college
student has been fighting a bank after
scammers stole her student loan money
she says the bank refuses to return it
to her 8 news now education reporter
Joshua figuero Joins us live tonight
with more Joshua
yes Sasha Katie Hoffman says Chase Bank
is refusing to listen to her her loan
meant for books and rent was allegedly
stolen by scammers and all this stress
comes out of time when she's preparing
for final exams
being a student and the wire transfer
money that was stolen 7 500 of a FAFSA
student plus loan so that was my money
to live on while I finished school
and now I'm kind of left high and dry
Katie Hoffman graduates this year with
her doctoral degree in occupational
therapy but her experience at UNLV went
sideways when she received a text in
February when I rece received that text
message I went ahead and answered the
text message which I received before for
fraud and the message claimed to be from
Chase alerting her to wire fraud she
clicked on a link that her phone rang
from the same number that was on the
back of my Chase bank account bank card
Hoffman answered some personal questions
such as the names of two of her closest
family members she says the rep told us
she'd get a call the next day but it
never came she noticed 7 500 in her
account was gone Hoffman started getting
a Sinking Feeling here I am still
fighting chaste for information and for
my student loan to be returned to me
Hoffman reported this to several federal
and state law enforcement agencies the
bank told her she quote authorized the
transfers and then added there was no
Bank error on our part in a statement to
8 news now Chase says quote we tried to
recover the funds without success we
urge all consumers to ignore phone or
Internet requests for money
now Chase adds that banks will never
call text or email ask if you were to
send money yourself or anyone else to
prevent fraud Hoffman is still holding
out hope that she can get her loan back
reporting live near Maryland Sahara
Joshua peguero eight news now thank you
Joshua now another tip to protect your
money is to never click on suspicious
links which can grant anyone remote
access to your phone or computer